la semaine suivante
ma chérie j'ai peine à croire qu
utilisent cette lettre en amérique
de l'autre côté de l'océan j'ai été ravi
voir que vous aviez encore sûr qu'ils
croyaient dire l'enjeu suffit de
regarder il me passe en volume ont fini
tinée faisant ses avoirs
j'ai rencontré un italien
l'atonie de l'impression d'avoir une vie
ici ce qui n'était pas vrai avant que je
le rencontre qui aurait tout de même pu
prévenir qu'il fallait que je mette mon
agent tout le monde mais en dessous
quand est ce que l'enterrement aura lieu
tu va vouloir entrer en irlande comment
tu prendrais toi tu rentres pays
ça me fait rire elle prépare que j'ai
envie
islamique est pareil je suis ravie de
faire votre connaissance
dre des plages a manqué c'est pas du
tout la même chose
et que farrell que j'ai vu dans la
voiture c'est un très bon parti je
m'étais imaginé mener une autre aux
iphone tu pourrais avoir une belle vie
ici aussi plus belle
charteau ni je veux que tu saches que je
suis plus
mieux vaut mieux reste ici